قصه يعني خلينا نقول مسار اهتمام العالم
كانت الايام الماضيه وهي الحادثه المؤسفه
اللي صارت معاه الشاب الروسي فلاديمير
اللي عمره كان 23 سنه وفقد حياته بسبب
هجوم من سمكه قرش في الغردقه بمصر الجديد
اليوم انه تقرير وزاره البيئه عن الحادثه
طلع وتضمن ان الهجوم صار على مسافه 50 متر
من خط الساحل بمنطقه مياه ضحلى ما بيتعدى
عنقها ثلاثه امتار وهي منطقه يعني معتاد
دائما فيها السباحه وفيها عدد من الكائنات
البحريه مثل الشعب المرجانيه والطحالب
وغيرها وانه سمكه القرش اللي هاجمت الشاب
الروسي فضلت اكثر من ثلاث ساعات متواصله
في المكان وانه خروجه لسطح الماء سلوك مو
طبيعي وانه عمليه الهجوم تمت بغرض التغذيه
المباشره على الضحيه واكد تقرير وزاره
البيئه انه المنطقه اللي صار فيها الحادث
ما فيها اي اعمال بتتسبب باثاره القرش
والتعرض لهجماته
ومن الاخبار الجديده اليوم
ما كان سائح مثل ما كان الكل مفكر ونقل
الاعلام في البدايه لا الشاب كان جاي هو
وعائلته علشان يستقروا في مصر حسب مسرح
والده اللي قال انه مجهز كل الاوراق
اللازمه علشان يستقر في مصر ودخل في شراكه
مع احد ابناء الغردقه للاستثمار
والاستيراد والتصدير بين مصر وروسيا
وخلال تقديم واجب العزاء من السكرتير
العام لمحافظه البحر الاحمر للوالد قال
انه اللي صار مع ابنه قضاء وقدره وبيرفض
المتاجره بالحادث او انه هذه مو المره
الاولى اللي بيجي فيها الغردقه وخلال
الساعات الماضيه انتشر على المنصات فيديو
لسائح روسي مع راقصه في مطعم وقال
المتداولين انه اخر فيديو للشاب الراحل
لكن بعد البحث والتدقيق اتضح انه هذا خبر
مزيف والفيديو
دكتور محمد خلينا نبتدي من النقطه الاخيره
اللي هي نقلتها صحيفه المصري اليوم نقلا
عن مراصد هل فعلا كان في اجهزه لتتبع
اسماك القرش موجوده عندكم ولكن لم يتم
استخدامها
لا طبعا هي الاجهزه طبعا دي احنا
استوردناها مخصوص عشان نستعمالها بس
استعمالها مرتبط بوقت معين عشان نقدر نعظم
الاستفاده من النتائج اللي احنا
نتحصل عليها من خلال استخدام هذه الاجازه
لان القبر مرتبط بسلوكيات الانواع من
اسماك المستهدفه بهذه الدراسه عشان نقدر
نفهم سلوكها الحركي خلال عام كامل
فبالتالي تركيبها مرتبط بوقت معين عشان
حتى كمان عشان نقدر نتحصل على العينات من
الاسماك اللي احنا هنركب عليها الاجهزه
نفسها
الامر مرتبط بمواسم تزاوج واماكن ظهور هذه
الاسماك في اماكن معينه في اوقات معينه في
السنه طيب يعني فالموضوع ما له علاقه انه
لو كنتوا استخدمتوا هذه الاجهزه ما كان
صار اللي صار لا لا الاجهزه ديت احنا
جبناها ضمن برنامج شامل وزاره البيئه
بتتبناه من اكثر يمكن من 12 سنه لان احنا
بدايه اهتمام وزاره البيئه بظاهره هجوم
اسماك القرش على البشر بدات يمكن من 12
سنه مش وليده هذا الحادث او قبل كده يعني
احنا اشتغلنا على الموضوع دوت وكل ما
بنشتغل طبعا
كل ما بتظهر اسئله محتاجه اجوبه فبالتالي
كان فكره الاستعانه بهذه الاجهزه الحديثه
على اساس نقدر من خلالها نقدر نجاوب على
بعض الاجهزه اللي مازال الاسئله
غامضه بالنسبه الان في الحاله اللي صارت
صار في كثير تضارب عن سبب انه القرش اكل
السائح في ناس كانت بيقولوا انه القرش كان
بيبحث عن اكل في ناس بيقولوا انه كان او
كانت حامل لانها انثى فكانت قريبه من الشط
في ناس بيقولوا انه لا كانت ولدت وبتحاول
تحمي مواليدها كانت في حاله هستيريه هل
فهمتوا ايش السبب
المجهودات دول ثانيه اشتغلت كتير على نفس
الطائره الدول بتاعتها
التفسيرات دي كلها مش تفسيرات افتراضيه دي
نتائج ابحاث ودراسات تمت في دول بتتشابه
البيئه بتاعتها بشكل كبير مع البيئه
المصريه
والنوع ده من القروش بالذات او اللي
بيسموه تايجر شارك هو بعض الدراسات تمت في
دول اخرى وانتهت من خلال استخدام اجهزه
التتبع بس احنا لما انتم مسكتوا لتايجر
شارك ايش لقيته وهذا تحديدا احنا لقيناه
طبعا
وده كان بيتطابق مع الاستيراد اللي احنا
مفترضينه بناء على المشاهدات بتاعتنا خلال
السنين اللي فاتت وكانت ماتيور يعني ناضجه
جنسيا يعني وكانت في مرحله متوسطه من
مراحل تطور الاجنه جواها
استعدادا لوضع الاجنه وده نسبيا بيتطابق
مع النتائج العالميه اللي اهتمت بها دراسه
هذه الظاهره
كان بيقول انه الق يعاني او القرش
بنسوق التغذيه او قله التغذيه او انه بغرض
التغذيه بغرض التغذيه تبحث عن الاكل كانت
يعني هو ده عامل ثاني
هي لما كان معرفتها في المياه المفتوحه
للمياه الساحليه
بتستهدف من الموضوع دوت كذا حاجه الحاجه
الاولانيه انها تضع الصغار بتاعتها في
اماكن امنه لان وضع الاجنه في المياه
المفتوحه بيعرضها للافتراض بشكل سهل جدا
من خلال الانواع الاخرى من القروش وفي نفس
الوقت ما بتقدرش تلاقي احتياجاتها من
الغذاء احنا بنتكلم دلوقتي على سمكه صغيره
الحجم محتاج انها تتوفر لها مصادر الغذاء
تتناسب مع احتياجاتها الغذائيه فدي اللي
انتهى اليه العالم في قصه تفسير هجره هذا
النوع من الاسماك اثناء مواسم التقاسم وهي
بتهاجر لو تسمحي لي بتحتاج تتغذى بشكل
كبير
لتوفير طاقه لدعم نمو الاجنه قبل عمليه
الولاده عشان
القروش او الصغار الاجنه لما تنزل تبقى
هيلتي لما بيقابلها صعوبات في هذا الامر
وما تلاقيش وفره الغذاء
اثناء عمليه الهجره ديت طبعا احتمالات
بحثها على مصادر اكل ثانيه بتزيد فقد يكون
دوت الى زياده معدلات هجوم هذا النوع من
القروش
خلال هذه الفتره ودي برضك نتائج توصل
اليها العالم احنا من خلال استخدام
الاجهزه اللي احنا بنجيبها عايزين نتحقق
من نفس السيناريو اللي بيحصل في الدول
الاخرى بيتطابق مع بس دكتور محمد عشان بدي
استغل الوقت معك في ناس طلعوا وهاجموا
انكم انتم مسكتوا السمكه وقتل او القرش
وقتلته القرش وما الى ذلك كيف بتردوا على
هذه الاصوات
اللي حضرتك اللي هم بيتزاولوا هذه
الافتراضيه اعتقد هو بيغيب عنهم حقائق
علميه كتير يعني هو اسماك القرش يمكن مصر
من تعتبر الدوله الوحيده في العالم اللي
بتحمي اسماك القرش بشكل كامل طبقا للحكم
القانون لاهميه هذا الكائن للاتزان البيئي
والصناعه السياحه العالم كله ودي بردك
يعني اللي بيتداوله هذا الكلام غايب عنهم
حقيقه ان العالم بيصطاد 100 مليون سمكه
قرش سنويا ومعظم دول العالم المتقدم من
اكبر الدول اللي بتستهدف هذه الانواع
وخصوصا التايجر شارك
في بروتوكولات عالميه بتنظم التعامل مع
الحوادث هجوم اسماك القرش على البشر ومعظم
الدول هذه البروتوكولات بتنادي بمحاوله
قيد السمكه المتسببه في الحادث للحد من
تكرارها على الهجوم على انسان تاني وذلك
حفاظا على ارواح البشر لان بتعتبر دي من
ضمن اولويات معظم دول العالم وكذلك الوضع
في مصر سلوك السمكه اللي تم رصده بعد
الحادث اكد ان السمكه بتحاول تبحث عن
فريسه اخرى وده ظاهرا غير طبيعيه معظم
حوادث اسماك القرش اللي بتحصل بتبقى عاضه
واحده وبيترك الفريسه ويمشي على اساس ان
هو بيتيقن من العضه دي ان هذا الكائن ليس
من مصادر اكله لكن لما يعض مره واتنين
وتلاته ويبقى في المكان لمده ثلاث ساعات
وبناء على المشاهدات والدراسات اللي احنا
عملناها قبل كده في وزاره البيئه بياكد ان
هذه السمكه ان كانت طرقت في المياه بنسبه
90% كان هتهاجم انسان ثاني وتسبب وتسبب
وان هذا النوع من القروش لا يترك اصابات
احتماليه الوفاه منه بنسبه 100% تقريبا
مؤنث القرش سمكه القرش
مش اول حادثه تعملها انه سبق وان قالت انه
في اثنين ثانيين انت بتاكد هذا الكلام
يعني الان
حضرتك احنا حصل عندنا خلال ال15 اللي فاتت
15 سنه الماضيه تقريبا 22 حادث ايوه لا بس
دي دي تحديدا هذه السمكه تحديدا
من هذا النوع واحنا بنقول كل حاجز بيحصل
في مصر بيتم التحقيق في كل تفاصيله بناء
على بروتوكولات عالميه هذه الان اللي
لقطتوها الان تبعت السائح
الروسي يعني كانت اكله
انت تقصدي نفس النوع ولا نفس السمكه نفس
السمكه لا يستحيل يا فندم مستحيل يحصل ده
لا لا هو نفس النوع اه نفس النوع هاجم قبل
كده خمس مرات طيب اربع حالات وفيات وحاله
اصابه كانت في ثلاث سنين وتسعين الحاله
الاصابه الفائح انجليزي لكن هذه السمكه هي
اللي تسببت في حوادث قبل كده احنا اخر حد
عندنا
من اكثر من سنه وكان برضك تايجر شارك شكرا
على هذه التوضيحات ويعني وضحت لنا كثير من
اللغط اللي صاير على هذا الموضوع والتضارب
في الاقوال بنشكرك كان معنا من الغردقه
عبر الهاتف دكتور محمد سالم رئيس قطاع
حمايه الطبيعه في وزاره البيئه المصريه
شكرا لك